hola qué tal recuerda es el último vídeo
en el que estábamos hablando acerca de
cómo modelar la población trabajamos en
la idea de modelar de población como una
función del tiempo y en ese vídeo
dijimos ok qué tal si la tasa de cambio
de la población con respecto al tiempo
es proporcional a la población y bueno
estábamos diciendo en este caso que la
tasa de cambio que les era mientras la
población crezca y bueno fue en esa
ocasión cuando resolvimos esta ecuación
diferencial y encontramos la n de tema
que satisfacía esta ecuación y bueno nos
dimos cuenta que esa función que
resolvía esta ecuación diferencial es la
función exponencial y de hecho
funcionaba bastante bien la función
exponencial satisface esta ecuación
diferencial y de hecho hasta vimos cómo
podíamos graficar lo si nosotros tenemos
por aquí el hambre de eje de la
población y por aquí al eje del tiempo
es más vamos a poner que ésta es ni
población ok
y este es mi tiempo ok nosotros decíamos
bueno si empezamos en una población en
el subíndice cero entonces nuestro
crecimiento exponencial nos dice que
vamos a crecer a más o menos así justo
de esta manera ahora si recuerdas el
vídeo pasado dijimos bueno es que aquí
existe un problema qué tal si thomas
malthus estaba bien
es decir que el ambiente no puede
soportar más que una cierta población
máxima y para eso déjenme a utilizar
este color vamos a ver a una cierta
población máxima la cual vamos a llamar
acá qué tal si el ambiente no puede
soportar más que una serie de población
máxima de camps que va a ser esta de
aquí aquí tengo el valor de cam bueno
aquí claramente se ve que no puede
crecer infinitamente en este caso el
ambiente lo va a detener no sé tal vez
no exista el agua suficiente y tarde o
temprano faltan alimentos o recursos o
lo que sea que falten y es por eso que
este modelo de población no toma en
cuenta
especialmente si lo estamos viendo desde
la perspectiva malthusiana y fue justo
en ese momento que el matemático pf bird
y bueno espero que lo esté pronunciando
bien hizo un nuevo modelo matemático
sobre el crecimiento de la población
pues estoy seguro que él leyó el trabajo
de malthus y seguramente dijo debe de
haber un modelo que se ajuste mejor a
estas ideas así que aunque te parece
esta vez comenzamos de nuevo con otra
con una nueva ecuación diferencial la
voy a poner aquí la derivada de n con
respecto al tiempo ok vamos a fijarnos
en una ecuación exponencial ok pero en
esta ocasión vamos a tomarnos el
siguiente modelo bien pues qué te parece
si primero hacemos lo siguiente si
tenemos una población aunque sea menor
que este valor de camps que es la
población máxima
bueno pues suena muy tentador que esta
población crezca de una manera
exponencial así que vamos a ponerlo así
si tenemos una población pequeña
entonces voy a querer que r
por n déjame ponerlo con este color okay
tenga un crecimiento exponencial ahora
qué va a pasar si nosotros nos acercamos
el valor de cam bueno pues lo que
estaría muy bien es hacer que este
crecimiento o esta tasa de cambio tienda
a cero cuando nos estemos acercando a la
población máxima de acá
bueno pues estaremos bien que esto
atendiera a cero y como podemos lograrlo
bueno tal vez podamos multiplicar justo
esto que tenemos aquí por algo ok vamos
a multiplicarlo por algo que nos dé esta
propiedad lo que queremos es que cuando
n es pequeña cuando n es mucho más
pequeña que camps entonces esto crezca
como una función exponencial y entonces
este término de aquí sea cercano 1
mientras que cuando nosotros nos
acercamos acá entonces queremos que este
término de aquí sea cercano a 0 y bueno
como esto es muy importante
déjame escribir a ver si n n
mucho menor a mucho menor menor menor
que acá ok que acá lo que quiero es que
esto esto sea igual a 1 entonces quiero
que esto sea cercano a 1 ok entonces
tenemos una población que crece sin
límites el ambiente no nos restringe por
lo tanto vamos a tener una población que
puede tener bebés y estos bebés crecerán
y a su vez podrán tener más bebés y así
sucesivamente y esto nos va a dar pie a
regresar al modelo anterior justo a una
idea como un modelo anterior ahora qué
pasa a mí y déjame ponerlo aquí si n
tiende al valor de la población máxima
bueno si entiende acá entonces lo que
voy a querer es que este término o esta
expresión término
hermine ok tienda hacer esto quiero que
tienda a 0 es decir si esto tiende a 0
bueno pues pero por lo que sea me va a
dar 0 y entonces la tasa de cambio va a
atender a 0 y es que esto nos quiere
decir que la comida va a ser mucho más
escasa y entonces va a ser muy pesado
encontrar recursos y bueno cómo puedo
construir con n y camps algo que está
dentro de aquí de estos paréntesis que
cumpla estas propiedades es decir estas
dos son mis metas y de hecho sería muy
bueno que tú no intentará resolver por
ti mismo y que por pura diversión para
ustedes este vídeo e intente es
encontrar una expresión algebraica muy
sencilla que tuviera estas mismas ideas
bien ahora veamos lo siguiente qué te
parece si empezamos con un 1 y déjame
ponerlo ahora con este color 1 ok ya
esto qué te parece si le restamos si le
quitamos n / cam ok n está con este
color ok
n ya esto lo voy a dividir entre camps
que por cierto está con este color así
que déjenme atraparte por aquí y aquí
voy a poner acá y bueno quiero que te
des cuenta que este término de aquí
cumple justo con lo que nosotros
queremos cumplen que si nosotros tenemos
una n muy pero muy pero muy pequeña
entonces bueno aquí tenemos una pequeña
fracción de camps y por lo tanto cuando
yo lo quité de uno entonces me va a
quedar algo muy cercano a 11 - algo muy
pequeño es algo muy cercano 1 y entonces
esto se comporta como una función
exponencial ahora sí nosotros tenemos
una n que sea muy pero muy pero muy
cercana al valor de k
bueno pues date cuenta que esta
expresión va a ser cercana a 1 y uno
menos uno va a ser algo que va a tender
a cero
y entonces pero por lo que sea me va a
quedar que la tasa de cambio o el
crecimiento de la población va a tender
a cero ok y de hecho esta ecuación de
aquí que parece ser que nos sirve
bastante bien no solamente es una
ecuación que nos ayuda a entender el
crecimiento de las poblaciones y de
hecho este de aquí es una ecuación
diferencial muy importante que bueno
además de decirnos cómo se comporta el
crecimiento de las poblaciones también
se utiliza para otros modelos y de hecho
estoy casi completamente seguro que la
primera vez que se utilizó esta ecuación
diferencial fue pensando en el modelo de
crecimiento de población sin embargo
esta ecuación diferencial tiene un
nombre muy específico porque es una
ecuación diferencial que se utiliza
mucho esta ecuación diferencial se llama
ecuación
ecuación diferencial diferencial d
gerencial ok logística diferencial
logística logística ok y de hecho esta
ecuación diferencial logística es justo
lo que vamos a estudiar con mucha calma
en los siguientes vídeos y no sólo eso
en el vídeo siguiente vamos a resolver
esta ecuación diferencial logística que
por cierto
es un poco más laboriosa de encontrar la
solución que esta ecuación que tenemos
aquí pero tampoco es muy difícil esta
ecuación diferencial también se resuelve
por variables separables y utilizando un
método de integración que vamos a
recordar en el siguiente vídeo pero una
vez que ya encontremos la solución bueno
pues el nombre de la solución
y vamos a decirlo de esta manera am se
le conoce como la función logística
claro y bueno ahora lo que quiero hacer
es ver más o menos cómo se comporta esta
ecuación diferencial y que veamos más o
menos cuál es su gráfica y bueno para
eso debe bajar un poco la pantalla
no espera me gustaría que se vieran las
caras así que vamos a dejarla como por
aquí y vamos a dibujar dos ejes voy a
decir que este va a ser a mi eje de la
población y este para acá va a ser mi
eje del tiempo así que vamos a ponerlos
este de aquí es mi eje de la población
ok y este de aquí va a ser mi eje del
tiempo de lujo y bueno de hecho se
déjame bajar un poco más esta pantalla
porque luego me dicen que no se ve muy
bien qué es lo que pasa aquí abajo y lo
primero que quiero que veamos es un caso
muy especial que es lo que pasa cuando
tenemos una población
justo aquí cuando n vale 0 bueno si te
das cuenta si n vale 0 entonces se
cumple esta ecuación diferencial porque
la población va a ser 0 y entonces esto
va a ser cero y eso quiere decir que la
tasa de crecimiento se mantiene en cero
y eso es completamente lógico y
completamente cierto porque si nosotros
empezamos con una población de cero
bueno pues date cuenta que entonces no
vamos a tener poblador
y por lo tanto no va a haber nadie que
pueda tener hijos y entonces la
población nunca va a crecer en este caso
cuando la población base vale cero
tenemos una solución constante así que
déjame ponerlo aquí cuando n de t es
igual a cero tenemos una solución
constante porque nunca cambia y repito
esto tiene mucha lógica porque satisface
la ecuación diferencial logística que
tenemos aquí arriba y eso quiere decir
que si nosotros empezamos sin nadie en
esta población bueno pues nos vamos a
mantener de esa misma manera nadie va a
tener bebés y bueno el segundo caso muy
especial la segunda solución constante
es cuando n vale acá si por ejemplo aquí
tenemos el valor de cam bueno date
cuenta de lo siguiente bueno pues
entonces qué va a pasar si nuestra
población empieza en acá es decir si n
subíndices 0 empieza en campo bueno pues
darte cuenta que si nosotros empezamos
en k es decir en el tiempo igual a cero
entonces nuestra población se va a
mantener en campo y es que date cuenta
es lo siguiente si nosotros tenemos que
nuestra población
y es que bueno pues aquí me quedarían
que entre camps lo cual es 11 10 y
entonces la tasa de crecimiento de la
población va a ser cero dicho de otra
manera esta población no crece ni
disminuyen siempre se mantiene en que es
una solución constante y esto tiene
mucha lógica con lo que decía maltos si
nosotros tenemos a esta población
constante bueno tal vez maltos lo
pensaba de la siguiente manera crece un
poco y después disminuye por alguna
catástrofe y después va a volver a
crecer y después pasa otra vez este
umbral de la población máxima y llega
otra catástrofe y así se sigue ahora
este modelo y lo que me gusta es que no
forzosamente sigue la misma idea y la
misma noción de unas catástrofes lo que
dicen es que tiene otra solución
constante está de aquí mi solución
constante en el tema igual a camps es
decir que cuando nosotros llegamos a la
población máxima justo ahí nos vamos a
mantener estas dos soluciones son
soluciones desde
con diferencia logística pero son
soluciones constantes y bueno ahora me
voy a preguntar qué es lo que va a pasar
si empezamos con una cierta población
inicial que le voy a poner aquí en el
subíndice cero pero está en el subíndice
cero
voy a pedirle y déjame ponerlo aquí en
el subíndice cero voy a decir que es más
pequeña que camps es más pequeña que el
valor de la población máxima pero a su
vez voy a decir que sea más grande que
bueno cero es decir que si podemos tener
en esta ocasión bebés y bueno si
nosotros empezamos con esta en el
subíndice cero y vamos a suponer en un
principio que está en el subíndice cero
es muy pero muy pequeña
bueno pues date cuenta que es lo que va
a pasar en esta ecuación diferencial es
que este término va a dominar sobre este
y ojo recuerda que ahorita solamente voy
a hacer el esbozo de la gráfica de esta
ecuación diferencial logística en el
siguiente vídeo es cuando la voy a
resolver fíjate bien si empezamos con
algo muy pequeño supongamos que tenemos
un octavo
un décimo de esta población máxima bueno
pues aquí voy a tener un décimo de esta
población máxima y uno menos un décimo
va a ser nueve decimos lo que es muy
parecido a uno dicho de otra manera esto
se va a comportar como una ecuación
diferencial muy parecida a ésta que
teníamos acá arriba este término va a
dominar sobre este y por lo tanto esto
me dice que este de aquí va a ser mi
término dominante de esta ecuación
diferencial dicho otra manera este va a
ser el que va a dictar cómo se va a
comportar la tasa de crecimiento eso
cuando n es muy pequeña y bueno como
éste va a ser el que dicta entonces
fíjate que tenemos un crecimiento
exponencial entonces se va a ver más o
menos así vamos a empezar a crecer de
una manera exponencial ok pero en medida
en que nos vayamos acercando al valor de
campo entonces la tasa de cambio va a
empezar a cambiar si te das cuenta si
estamos muy cercanos el valor de acá
esto de aquí es muy cercano a 1 y
entonces cuando tenga 1 - algo muy
cercano a 1 esto va a ser así
lo que quiere decir que cuando nosotros
nos acercamos acá nuestra tasa de
crecimiento va a ir disminuyendo o de
otra manera tenemos como una asín total
valor de acá nuestra tasa de crecimiento
va a tender a cero poco a poco vamos a
crecer de una manera mucho menor y
entonces a más o menos se va a ver así
el comportamiento de esta población
inicial justo esta sería la forma del
esbozo de la gráfica de ecuación
diferencial y bueno todo depende de
donde empecemos si nosotros empezamos
por ejemplo aquí bueno pues entonces tal
vez vamos a tener un crecimiento a más o
menos así por otra parte es en nuestra
condición inicial empieza más o menos
como por aquí bueno pues va a ser va a
ver más o menos así el esbozo de nuestra
gráfica es decir algo más o menos así y
de hecho lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que no utilizamos matemáticas
elegantes en este vídeo para resolver
esta ecuación diferencial y sin embargo
hicimos un esbozo
y comportamiento de su gráfica y lo más
importante de todo esto con lo que
quiero que te quedes es que si tenemos
una condición inicial muy pero muy
pequeña entonces vamos a tener un
crecimiento parecido al crecimiento
exponencial
ok más o menos así y si nosotros tenemos
una condición inicial o nos vamos
acercando al valor de camps
entonces vamos a tener poco a poco una
tasa de cambio muy pero muy cercana a
cero se va a ver más o menos así nuestra
población casi no va a crecer y entonces
esta de aquí va a ser nuestra gráfica de
esta ecuación diferencial logística en
el siguiente vídeo vamos a resolver por
completo esta ecuación diferencial
logística y lo padre es que vamos a
poder corroborar si realmente tiene
sentido con esta idea que tenemos de
nuestra gráfica de nuestra ecuación
diferencial logística